-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me?"
My partner tonight
is an incredible actress
and has a new children's book
out now, called "Busy Betty."
Give it up for the one and only
Reese Witherspoon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, come on!
Welcome back, Reese!
-Thank you!
I'm so excited to be here!
-We love you.
Now, here's how the game works.
Reese and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
Could be people, objects,
anything.
Once the curtain opens
and you pick up your card,
you have 45 seconds
to try to get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want
or use gestures.
You just can't say any
of the words on your card.
Enough instructions?
-That's a lot of rules.
-All right, Reese,
you will be guessing first.
Let's get into position.
-Let's just see how this goes.
-Let's just see how this go--
oh.
-Wait.
-Look at this.
High budget.
-Ooh!
-This is --
This cost us $2 million.
Aaron Judge's home-run ball
paid for this.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I'm gonna guess.
-You're gonna guess.
-I think, right?
So, you're gonna --
You're gonna watch it.
-Reese -- all right,
let's open the curtain
and see what's behind you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, okay.
Uh...okay.
It's the first president
of the United States.
-George Washington.
-Yes.
And -- And, uh --
Uh, and, and, and, uh...
He's, uh --
There's a -- there's a baby --
there's a baby,
and the baby sits in...
-A stroller.
-When you're -- when you're --
when you're eating.
-In a high chair.
-Yep. And the baby
is a famous horror movie.
-Predator.
-For Halloween, Halloween.
-Oh, Jason!
The guy with the mask.
-The other "Halloween."
-"Scream" movie. Aah!
-No, the other "Halloween"!
[ Laughter ]
-He's a pumpkin!
He's a pumpkin!
-No, he's not a pumpkin.
Actually, in the movie
"Halloween."
-Jamie Lee Curtis!
-Yes, close.
But he's the person trying
to kill Jamie Lee Curtis.
-Jason! Jason!
-No, it's not Jason!
-Oh, oh!
Michael Myers! Michael Myers!
-Yes! That's correct.
[ Bell dings ]
George Washington feeding
Michael Myers in a high chair.
Can we see what it is?
-Oh!
-Well, hold on, sorry.
There you go.
-[ Screams ]
-He won't do it.
He doesn't want to eat it.
He doesn't want
to eat it at all.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so weird.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you for trying, George.
You did a great job trying.
-Yeah, that was just weird.
-He does not want to eat.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
-That was a good actor.
-Who's Jason?
-Jason's "Friday the 13th."
-Oh, yeah.
Wait.
That's not Freddy Krueger?
-That's
"Nightmare on Elm Street."
-Oh, thank you.
-I don't even know that many
horror movies.
-Okay.
-Now it's my turn to guess.
Here we go with
the million-dollar rotation.
Here we go.
Wow.
♪♪
♪ Unh, unh, oww ♪
-♪ Raow ♪
-All right.
Now, all right.
Grab the blue card, look at it,
and now we have
to open the curtain.
And then time starts
once you see what's behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Okay!
This guy --
-I love your laugh.
That is so good.
-He's one of the greatest
songwriters, okay?
-Oh, uh -- Paul McCartney.
-And he's been around
for a really long time,
and he loves to wear, like,
feathers and he --
-Elton John.
-Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He is doing something
that people used to do at --
I never, but --
[ Laughter ]
They never did this.
But you might have done this
as a kid at a Halloween party
in the '60s?
[ Laughter ]
The '80s?
Okay.
-Uh, trick-or-treating.
-No kid does this.
-No kid does this ever, no.
-No, but it's -- it has fruit.
-Oh, bobbing for apples?
-Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was good.
Okay, and then --
-Yeah, you're right,
no one does this, yeah.
-He's at America's
almost favorite breakfast place.
The --
[ Laughter ]
There's so many things
on the menu at this place, like,
you don't even know
what to choose, because --
-Waffle House?
-No, but thank you.
That is -- Yes, that's my
favorite breakfast place.
-Smothered and covered,
yeah, yeah.
-The next-best breakfast place.
-Denny's?
-Yes!
-What? Elton John
bobbing for apples at a Denny's?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he's being very picky.
[ Laughs ]
He's being very picky to see
which exact apple he wants.
Oh, that's not how you do it.
-No hands. No hands.
-No hands, Elton.
-No hands.
-Okay.
-People do not do that.
-Thank you very much, Elton.
-He's being very picky
and selective.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good job.
-Okay, very nice here.
Reese, it is your turn to guess.
Let's rotate.
♪♪
♪ Hey, I like to rotate ♪
♪ Yeah, cha, nah, la la ♪
Yeah, I love it.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see --
It's a new reggae song called
"Let's Rotate."
I don't know what that means.
All right,
let's see what's behind you.
Open the curtain, please.
[ Laughter ]
That's very funny.
Okay, it is --
[ As Yoda ]
He talks like this.
-Oscar the Grouch?
[ Laughter ]
-He says in --
-Yoda!
-[ Normal voice ] Yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's an action --
action figure --
it's an action figure
from the '80s.
-He-Man.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
They're doing something
very famous that's on TikTok.
-The squirrel dance.
Flossing.
-Uh, it involves...
-The Gritty.
-...hitting each other with...
-Oh, punching.
-No, but --
-Javelin.
-No, it's a -- it's a burrito --
-Throw a burrito?
-No. But a burrito --
[ Laughter ]
A burrito -- a burrito
is wrapped around --
-Chipotle.
-No, yes.
But -- but in a burrito,
the base of the burrito --
-Taco.
-No, but a burrito --
-Tortilla. Tortilla!
-Yes!
And they're using
the tortilla --
it's a big thing --
-Slap them with a tortilla.
-Yes! Exactly!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wait, you gotta --
Reese, you have to see this.
-[ Laughing ]
It -- okay, this is just --
oh!
-Oh, hey, whoa, He-Man!
All right, it's the final round.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are we doing?
-It's so silly.
I don't even understand.
All right, it's the final round.
Let's rotate.
-Okay.
-All right, it's the last --
We got this.
For all the --
♪♪
All right.
Now, it is time
to see what is behind me.
-What is behind him?
Okay.
-Yes, here we go.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
W-o-o-o-ow!
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
Now, and I'm gonna hurry,
because this is gonna --
this might not last very long.
-Okay, all right.
-So I'm gonna hurry.
Okay, okay.
So, this --
you would find these in Egypt.
-A pyramid.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh...
Just the greatest movie ever.
Tim Burton, and -- and you say
his name three times.
-Beetlejuice!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, and --
Beetlejuice is at the pyramid.
-Yeah, but they're in
a very famous place.
It's the city
of romance and love.
-France!
-Yes, France!
[ Bell dings ]
-At the Eiffel Tower?
-Yes!
Okay, so, yes, it is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...a pyramid of Beetlejuices
in Paris.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, I -- see, now I get it.
-Yeah.
-All right, we both
got credit for that one.
Reese Witherspoon, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done, dude.
It was very good.
We're talking to Reese
after the break!
Stick around, everybody!